you know some folks get in trouble for
the things they say
some folks get in trouble for choosing
to stay quiet
chris pratt has managed to get in
trouble for doing a combination of the
two
[Music]
hello there folks now before anyone
scratches their head really confused no
there hasn't been like some big breaking
controversy around chris pratt
however you may have noticed over the
past several years it's been kind of
largely agreed by the internet at large
that of the big hollywood chris's which
include pratt hemsworth pine and evans
chris pratt's the worst and i'm not
actually here to necessarily dispute
that
but along with that designation as the
worst chris has come an increasing
amount of
scrutiny of
hostility
towards him
and
i have found myself wondering
is isn't warranted
now understand i'm not actually here to
give a full-throated defense of chris
pratt but i'm kind of of the opinion in
general that we should hold people
accountable to the things that they
actually do
but when i look at
the certainty with which i see people
on twitter in my own comments section on
this platform on others talk about chris
pratt and like well he's he thinks this
and how certainly they say that and then
i go looking for it and i'm like
i'm i can't say that you are
definitely wrong but there isn't a lot
that you're basing that level of
certainty on and that's kind of what i
want to talk about here so what i'm
going to do in this is i am going to
talk about the point in time at which
the general opinion towards chris pratt
started to turn
i'm going to talk about
what people's persistent issues appear
to be i'm going to talk about some of
the reasons why i think this has
possibly been blown up more than it is
worth
and then uh we're going to wrap up on a
little bit of a different note but uh
hang on we'll get there
so let's start by
covering for anyone who was ever
confused
what's the issue with chris pratt
exactly now trouble for chris pratt at
least in terms of public image and
perception seems to largely start in
2018 in particular
most people would cite his acceptance
speech at the mtv movie awards that year
as being kind of the kickoff for
folks starting to give him side eye and
be like i don't know about this guy in
his acceptance speech for i believe it
was the generation award i'm not even
really sure what that is and i don't
care enough to look it up but he gave a
speech that has kind of come to be known
as the chris pratt's nine rules speech
it was a mix of sincere sentiment and
flat out jokes
but it was rule number six that seemed
to grab the most attention from people
number six
god is real
god loves you god wants the best for you
believe that i do
he then immediately followed that up on
instructions on how to poop at a party
without completely stinking out the
entire bathroom which again as i said
this was a mix of sincere sentiment and
jokes
so
what is it about that statement well for
one thing it's a bit unusual
for folks in hollywood to do much more
than just go
like
my thanks to god that's usually where it
stops if religion is going to enter into
the conversation at something like an
award ceremony
his statements were a little bit more
declarative they were said more like
statements of facts than beliefs
and that seemed to be the point of which
people started to wonder wait a minute
is he like
super religious
is that a potential
issue
because it's actually hard to know how
religious a lot of hollywood is but the
general perception of hollywood is that
it's pretty a-religious and a lot of
that has to do with the political
perception of hollywood as being
incredibly left-leaning and the
political
perception of religions being
right-leaning now
we could do an entire separate
conversation about how accurate that is
in either case but that is generally
kind of the public perception and i do
think his evocation of this idea that
god is real god loves you and god wants
the best for you that kind of got people
wondering and this is also probably
where
the lgbtqia plus community started
getting worried about him or kind of um
maybe was a little bit of let's go with
an orange flag for that
if you don't understand why that is
terms like
god loves you
it sounds at worst innocuous kind of
sounds nice
except that if you're any shade of queer
it's something that has been
said or possibly shouted at you
as a justification for people
who treat you horribly
if you've never
come across videos online of people
shouting
about queerness with great anger and
claiming that they're doing it for our
own good because god loves us and
doesn't want us to go to hell yeah
we deal with that a lot
so someone speaking in those kinds of
terms even when they are not being
presented in an anti-queer context it's
going to
trigger
certain memories and associations for a
lot of queer people which again is why i
suspect that this initial statement
while
just slightly unusual on its own was was
where attention started to be getting
focused on him
after that the following year in 2019 he
appeared on the late show with stephen
colbert and during his appearance there
he did talk a little bit about his faith
in his religion not in great detail but
just a little bit there's this great
quote that i actually heard in church
and it felt
like it really appropriate which was
if the spotlight that's shining on you
is brighter than the light that that
comes from within you it'll kill you
following that appearance elliott page
tweeted out criticisms specifically
lashing out against pratt for attending
a quote infamously
anti-lgbtq church
now this is where the hate really
started to get
drummed up now
i also need to do some clarifying here
because there was a lot of misreporting
especially at the time a lot of people
seem to be assuming for reasons that
aren't 100 clear well i kind of know why
this happened but we'll get there but a
lot of people and it's unclear if elliot
page was making this uh connection but a
lot of people sort of picking up the
torch and running with it
associated chris pratt with the hillsong
church now the hillsong church is an
evangelical church has a number of
locations across the world including in
los angeles and that church some of its
leaders in particular have on a number
of occasions made
anti-lgbtqia plus statements
however
pratt
didn't go to hillsong church he didn't
then he doesn't now and that's not like
well he says he doesn't but what do we
know like it not only has he
more recently and we'll get into the
timeline on this a little bit but more
recently said i've never attended that
church but brian houston one of the
church leaders and also one of the guys
who made anti-queer statements
also confirmed chris pratt was never a
member of his church
although to be fair before that he did
muddy the waters by praising prat for
sticking up for the actor's church in a
way that made it very easy to assume
that that church was hillsong so if
pratt never went to that church
why was he being linked to it well the
church he actually goes to is the zoho
church now the zo church in l.a was
started by someone named chad vich who
was
formerly
a preacher at hill's song now even since
leaving hillsong veach has not been
controversy free i found a number of
sources attributing a quote to him from
2017 linking the idea of same-sex
relationships and attractions being a
form of sexual brokenness but when i
actually track down the sourcing on that
to call it a quote from him is
misleading that's a description that
appears in an article that he was
interviewed for but it's not an actual
quote by him it is in reference to a
film that he was the executive producer
on a film called the heart of man now
whether or not that sentiment is
accurate to what's in the film or how
much of the film itself is actually
representative of veich's exact thoughts
since he is only an executive producer
and not say the director or the writer
is just really hard to parse and i can
find very little information on thing
the thing's only got one review on
rotten tomatoes and i'm not gonna try
and dig it up and watch it myself my
overall point being that veach has some
ties to anti-lgbtqia plus sentiments but
they are fairly indirect certainly
compared to the people who ran hillsong
it's really unclear if it's actually
preached or intended as part of the
religious practice there which that
pratt has denied actually in the wake of
paige's uh tweets he said it's been said
that i go to an anti-queer church that
is the furthest from the truth now the
thing is though at that point in time he
didn't clarify what church he went to he
simply said that's not true about the
church i go to and a lot of news pieces
at the time seemed to take it as he was
defending hillsong church but again
that wasn't actually his church he was
defending the church he actually went to
which was zoe church although again in
his statements he didn't clarify
that that was where he went
i'll also make note that even if you
want to take issue with the zoe church
because as i said the uh the guy who
started that has said some not great
things although it's nothing compared to
the uh controversies that have come out
of hillsong because anti-queer sentiment
is not the beginning and end of the
issues with that church for the record
but the thing is chris pratt is not the
only celebrity who attends zoe church
there are a number of others including
justin bieber maria shriver and selena
gomez and it's worth noting particularly
with selena gomez
she
has been an ally to the lgbtqia plus
community now i'm not saying that in
like well because she's an ally and goes
to the same church that means that this
other guy who goes to the same church as
an ally i'm not saying that but what i
am saying is
it's a little weird to me that so far as
i can tell
he's the only member of that church
that has been kind of singled out for
being called out about this i haven't
seen call outs i wasn't able to find
much in the way of call-outs of any of
the other celebrities and the reason i
highlight selena gomez is because she
has supported
queer causes you would think she would
be someone to call out if it was
genuinely believed to be an anti-queer
church but i couldn't really find that
that was happening
so the question then becomes
why chris pratt
well i think there's a couple reasons
as i mentioned he'd already kind of
brought up his religion so that was
something that people were latching on
to
gomez hasn't had the same kind of public
declarations of her faith the way that
pratt has therefore the same scrutiny
just hasn't been leveled at her and i'm
not saying that it should be to be clear
this is not a well let's go get selena
gomez again i'm just kind of making the
comparison and his belief in god is
something that he's reaffirmed a couple
of times in a few other interviews since
that initial speech that he gave at the
mtv awards now as i mentioned before
there is frequently a presumption that
someone who is outwardly vocally
religious
is probably
right leaning
now this again as i said before may or
may not be fair there's a lot of ways to
practice faith in this country and
indeed the world
the thing is though
the religious organizations that have
opted to get political have pretty much
all sided with the right with the
evangelical church and the rel the
religious right just as a thing being
the primary example is there a religious
left
i mean
yes insofar as there are certainly
religious people on the left but it's
not organized in the same way and so
there is a general public perception
increasingly i think that religion
equals
right leaning at least if not right wing
because the religious right is honestly
behind some of the most heinous stuff
that the right pushes but i'm gonna try
and not get too bogged down in the
politics but i'm saying that perception
of someone who's outwardly proclaiming
their love in god and their belief in
god
people are going to make some
assumptions
and as i said he didn't clarify things
for a long time
but before i come back to when he did
finally start clarifying stuff on a
separate note from the religious stuff
there was also an incident that occurred
on the sets of park and recreation where
there's a scene in which chris pratt is
meant to appear naked and normally you
have sort of flesh-colored modesty
assurance they put a blur effect and he
decided to actually be nude for that
scene which was frankly inappropriate
and while it frankly does irritate me
that he recounts this story without much
remorse and kind of a cavalier attitude
i know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna drop my trowel as an improv it
does appear that it has not happened
since then he got his warning and he
stopped which is in contrast to somebody
who i've talked before that being john
barrowman who had a list of incidents
including some that happened after he
was reprimanded does that make the
original incident okay no it does not
but it does at least reflect a change in
behavior following that kid there is a
protocol to being naked you must give
everyone the option to not see it but
even in his kevlar attitude pratt has
never really defended himself he hasn't
doubled down actually he hasn't really
doubled down over any of the stuff we're
talking about probably most recently
there was a little bit of an indirect
thing with the show that pratt is on
called the terminalist the show got torn
apart by critics and the writer of the
original novel that the show is based on
jack carr took to social media to decry
woke critics on his instagram chris
pratt reposted that following it
immediately with this meme image
bragging about how many minutes the show
has been watched on streaming childish
certainly exhibiting anti-woke
sentiments uh maybe i think one could
make the case that he's more supporting
the person who initiated the show he's
on rather than trying to back up that
specific sentiment but again it's just
kind of muddy it's something to add into
the make sure but i don't think it's
especially stable and as we've already
been dealing with there is some
misreporting or the very least some
misleading headlines implying that he's
the one who said these things when he is
not there is one other thing that i
think
is at least a partial factor if only
subconsciously and that is the fact that
chris pratt is
i'm gonna go with
kind of a limited actor i don't think
he's necessarily a bad actor but he
doesn't appear to have a very great
range he plays a very similar
kind of bro-y slightly douchey kind of
character in most things that he's in
now when he's placed in the right
project that can work incredibly well as
it does i feel in guardians of the
galaxy or it can really clash with what
the film is trying to be or what his
character is theoretically supposed to
be in something like say the jurassic
world franchise but that impression that
he doesn't have a
really big range as an actor
makes it very easy to assume
that that's basically what he's like in
real life
now that may be true it may not be
but again i don't think that's something
people consciously have decided but i
wouldn't be surprised if it's a factor
it probably doesn't help that he got
divorced from anna faris a few years
back now we actually don't know a ton
about that divorce it appears to have
been largely amicable uh so far as i
could find but you know it's one more
thing for people to make a lot of
assumptions around
now i said we would come back to when he
actually started um clarifying things
and we will but first i want to talk
about that gap in time as i said he did
reply kind of
fairly promptly to elliott page's
initial call out on twitter but it was
just to say i don't go to an anti-queer
church kind of left it at that and as i
said in my opening bit sometimes
choosing to be quiet
can get you in trouble
and
as i have brought up elsewhere before
when you
don't clarify what it is you do actually
believe what you actually think
it can leave the window open for people
to make assumptions and oftentimes
especially with celebrities
it's going to be negative assumptions or
assumptions that you wouldn't like them
to make i think the classic example of
this at this point is taylor swift who
at right now is a fairly vocal
democratic supporter but for a while she
was
not talking about politics at all and
given her fan base was a mix of you know
young girls with an interest in pop and
more country-leading people which tends
to be a much more conservative audience
from a career standpoint it made sense
for her not to talk politics because she
was going to risk alienating one part of
her base
but eventually she got to the point
where she did start talking about
politics but prior to that
there was a frighteningly large and
devout following on the far
right who were convinced
she was one of them and it was pretty
much based entirely on her never stating
otherwise
now that's an extreme example obviously
i'm not saying it's that extreme with
chris pratt but i'm using to illustrate
the fact that if you don't say
how things actually are
people will not only start to make
assumptions but they may well run with
those assumptions and try and cash them
in for
far far far more than they are worth in
reality
and chris pratt seems to have
potentially suffered from this a little
bit if we presume that the statements he
actually made earlier this year are in
fact accurate and those being as i said
before his statement that he never went
to the hillsong church which does appear
to be accurate and is corroborated
but he also did give a little bit of an
insight into why he didn't
bring this up before why he didn't
specifically
condemn hillsong
and he was kind of you know he said i
don't go to an anti-lgbtqia plus church
but he wasn't very specific about it and
that vagueness probably hurt his
position in the public image basically
what he said was
i don't want to throw another church
under the bus although interesting he he
was very quick to add on to that that
it's not a hard rule because he actually
said you know if it's the westboro
baptist church that's something
different and actually in that same
interview this is all from an interview
with men's health by the way in that
same interview he also
expressed an understanding that
religious observance and religious
practice and being a religious person
is not exactly the same thing as what
happens under organized religion he
did lay out very plainly his
understanding that what is done in the
name of religion versus simply being a
religious person
is some pretty terrible stuff and
actually his exact words were that
religion historically has been
oppressive as [ __ ]
now those are pretty strong words
and one can't help but think that if he
had said that
three years ago
maybe the current public perception of
him wouldn't be what it is
so that's sort of my initial explanation
for why i feel like it it just makes me
uncomfortable when people talk in such
certain terms chris pratt thinks this
he's a bad person because he believes
this when we know he is a believer he is
a religious person but exactly what he
believes
it's kind of a lot of conjecture
projection and hearsay it's not backed
up by much now that's not me saying that
it's impossible that he does in fact
harbor anti-queer sentiments he might i
don't know
i'm saying there isn't a ton of actual
concrete evidence that he does though
no more for other people who aren't
getting called out on this
i could
end it there i could just close out the
video and we could be done
but the thing is i kind of want to take
a swerve
and go out on a limb
and i hope you'll come with me on this
let's say
for the moment that hypothetically
everything that is believed negative
about chris pratt is in fact true
that he is right-wing that he harbors
anti-lgbtqia plus sentiments
and all of that let's assume for the
moment that all that is 100 true not
even up for debate
if we take that as an assumption but we
still look at him for what he has done
how he behaves and what he's doing what
he said
even if he believes those things i would
still argue
maybe we should back off a little bit
i'll try to explain i do think this
branch that i've gone out on will
support my weight now there's a couple
of other things that i should add into
the mix before i go too much further out
on this branch
so the first is in terms of his politics
he has never really publicly sided with
either republicans or democrats he
actually appears to be something of a
centrist what he said is he doesn't feel
that either side represents him the only
political donations that i could find
was that he donated a thousand dollars
to the re-election campaign of barack
obama so that was in 2012.
other than that i can't find a lot of
political engagement from him either
statements or financial support or
endorsing anybody
as far as charity goes which can
sometimes be a really good indicator
because you know some charities are
sketchy and like well that just looks
like a tax shelter some
charities are in fact up to some rather
insidious stuff autism speaks springs to
mind but
in terms of his charitable donations
over the last
seven years or so
well it's pretty much all been
teen centers
food banks in more recent years also
some significant donations for a
neonatal intensive care unit along with
efforts to provide eyeglasses to
underprivileged children
so
his charitable donations i'm not putting
these out to be like and he's a great
guy i don't know i don't know him but
i'm saying that there's not a lot of
political insight from those so again
let's come back to my hypothetical
he believes that
queer people are lesser however you want
to word it all of these things that
people say that we should be canceling
him over they're all true he believes
all these things
but what is he actually doing
someone in his position
can potentially do a lot of damage
with a belief like that
but the way they can do that damage
is through influence making use of their
celebrity and their platform to push a
harmful ideology
or financially either donating directly
or helping to campaign on behalf of
people who will push that harmful
ideology
and he's not doing either one
what that means to me as a practical
matter
is that
even if he believes all these things
the most damage he can possibly be doing
is with
his own single solitary vote
and the thing is as much as i would
love
love to be in a world where everybody
just accepts queer people
everybody's okay with it
not only do we not live in that world
now i think it's naive to
assume we ever will
we need
just for the sake of
existing
to a certain degree need to be okay with
people who
maybe don't support us
but are not actively harming us
i know it's very easy
to slip into uh you're either with us or
against this mentality which again leans
into the well he hasn't openly supported
queer causes etc and so it's easy to
assume well then he must be against us
and
even if he is in his head he's not
taking action against us
i've said in the past that
i care much more about what you do
than what you think
i care a lot more about the consequences
of a person's actions than i do the
thoughts or beliefs that motivate them
now in the past i've used that in
reference to
people who will claim you know oh i'm
not
anti-trans but then
donate to or defend or otherwise promote
people who are anti-trans
and there is a disconnect there between
your words and your actions and maybe
even in your head you do
not harbor anti-trans sentiments
but if you are bolstering
and enabling and empowering
those sentiments
even if you don't say them yourselves if
you are supporting them
then the consequences of your actions is
harm to trans people and i care more
about the consequences than your beliefs
but that works in the other direction as
well
if you believe that i'm lesser that i
shouldn't have the same rights as other
people that i shouldn't legally be
allowed to
marry or whatever else
but you're not
getting on a platform to preach that
if you're not actively campaigning on a
basis for that if you're not donating
significant sons of money to any
organization that is trying to bring
that about
at least
grant me that
with someone like that my energy would
better be spent elsewhere
than hammering on somebody
who doesn't like me but isn't doing
anything with that
maybe this is where i show my age a
little bit
because i can remember a time before
trump
before
someone like him
rose to the highest position of power
and basically waved the flag to say it's
okay to start saying the quiet parts out
loud
and i'm also not going to say that just
thinking
anti-trans anti-queer anti-abortion
whatever thoughts are is harmless just
holding those beliefs is harmless it's
not
that's still a problem but it's not the
immediate problem we need to be dealing
with right now
and it might be a problem that we have
to come to a certain degree of
acceptance with
because things have gotten
worse
and they've gotten worse because of the
actions people take and these are
actions chris pratt
is not taking
now if you feel like i'm just going well
you could be a lot worse then
okay maybe
but is this the guy that it's worth
sinking time energy emotional investment
into disliking
i mean
not to be a dick about it but
it doesn't even seem worth it
we can't
get everyone to like us but we need to
put our focus on the people who are
actively harming us
and the people who are actively enabling
them
do i wish
that
he would flat out
be supportive of lgbtqia plus people yes
yes i do
but his not doing that
doesn't make him my enemy
i'm not prepared to go all or nothing
on this i am not at a place
where i believe you have to be
exactly where i am
or we have a problem
and
please believe me
i have
very very few facts left to give
when it comes to
political issues
and support of
most of what the republican party and
the and the far right are doing
or standing for or trying to do there
are relatives i have who i don't talk to
anymore
because
i know where they stand on things and i
can't be comfortable around them and
would i be comfortable in a room with
chris pratt i don't know
probably not
but i don't have to be in a room with
him either
his actions are not harming me
not from anything that i can find and if
i missed something if i missed a more
definitive statement or something that
he has done or campaigned for or said or
donated to that wasn't covered
tell me
and i'll reconsider
but for what i could find and i'm not
saying you have to like him
i'm not sure how much i like him but the
whole chris pratt boom cancel him recast
star lord why i don't understand the
foundation for that is very flimsy and
also like it's worth acknowledging and i
don't again i don't know if this is the
case i don't know chris pratt but
some people just aren't comfortable
defending themselves
one has to wonder if that's the case
with someone like him given how long it
took him to even clarify the thing about
the church and that he you know he's
using a line like i don't want to throw
another church under the bus
he seems like somebody who did not think
that his speaking about god at that
award ceremony would cause a problem and
who doesn't really seem to know how to
deal with it now that it has
which is probably why some people who do
know him because again i don't like say
director james gunn have come out with
pretty full-throated defenses of the guy
these are people who actually know him
and
james gunn in particular is an
interesting case because he's someone
who has not only been working on himself
for a long time very publicly but has
literally made his career deconstructing
toxic masculinity and a lot of the stuff
that is being slung at chris pratt for
being an embodiment of
does that mean we must believe daddy
james gunn no it doesn't mean that
either
i'm not gonna tell you what to think and
if you still think chris pratt is the
devil somehow
okay
you can think that i i do think
collectively
a lot of folks are kind of being unfair
to chris pratt
and yes i know poor multi-millionaire
movie star i'm not here i'm not here to
defend the guy but
i think we should hold people
accountable to what they actually do
what they actually say
not what we assume they think
hopefully if i explain myself well
you'll understand where i'm coming from
from all this if i explain myself badly
uh comment sections are going to be a
nightmare on this we'll see what happens
in either case
whatever your thoughts are keep them
polite
no personal attacks against me against
pratt against anybody in the comments no
personal attacks as long as you can rein
that in whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
patreon is what pays the bills if you
like my content i would
really appreciate and can really use the
help things have been a bit on the tight
side lately youtube is
not treating me well and the other way
you can help that
wouldn't cost you any money would be to
like share and subscribe
but
as much as i would appreciate it
what i really want you to remember
is you're beautiful
you are valid
you are
loved you are the council i'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin lutfullah tarak the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelkey
theotha boyd becky sparks fernaby likes
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper adam rdl taylor shane ross
shaylee gourley brandon larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards my
patreon
[Music]